He's easy, easy.
And that's full blowning
my cover in Tehran.
Clive.
And believe I agreed to this,
You simply took a series of beats
within two meters of the laptop
for 60 seconds.
Everything will happen to us.
The team has been working
to crack the thumb drive overnight,
Feel good about their.
Here you go.
Thanks,
Mr. Ellison. Please call me Debbie.
Oh, Debbie. Thank you.
The information on this thumb drive
may well be key in finding spymaster
having Harmon Taylor loose on U.S.
soil is bad for both our countries.
Is it true that he has never been caught?
Not yet, no.
Scuse me.
So, what are you doing here? Spot
out. It's classified, sir.
Your position is very good.
Everything our team is interfacing
in encryption on this looks a bit tasty.
Do you think you'll manage to crack it?
I'm sorry. Why are you here?
And so close?
But I'm just lonely, curious, that's all.
I want to see how it's done
on this side of the pond, Mr.
Strange.
To just talk it with your name.
30 seconds more. Steve.
Steve. Out in 2 seconds.
Think you should be going?
The team has a lot on their plate,
but straight up,
it'll probably take me a couple more days.
And whoever designed this rig is,
I must insist. Mr.
Aston, this area is not typically
for foreign agents.
Apology. Steve.
Thank you.
You moved too soon.
No need to be impatient
right now.
I'm sorry.
I must just ask, how do you work
with this noise going on in here?
Surely your superiors can find a way to
dampen the sound of the surface in here.
It's not the servers
they solve and fix the toilet.
Upstairs we put in three
facilities request this week.
The toilet upstairs
goes.
The camellia beads
transmit through concrete.
Right? Of course.
Well,
apologies for this.
Did I just hear the toilet flush?
The steel pipes should amplify the signal
from the beads
interfacing for a second time.
There you go.
It's finished.
And the laptop itself.
Well, now it's useless.
I'll kick it back to the CIA.
Should have it by tomorrow.
Thank you. Ever.
You better retrieve the beads.
I got to go haul
the British spy out of my trunk.
Welcome back, everyone.
Is Charlie
Marvel released a bunch of Black Panther
Wakanda forever deleted scenes.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references here,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
because Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania is coming out
so soon,
we're doing a giveaway for IMAX tickets.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post your favorite moment from, well,
kind of forever on the video.
Careful first photos from the movie
if you haven't seen it yet.
But in this scene, Everett Ross is pulling
a Sherlock doing some detective work.
They didn't say it was inspired
a little bit by his series Sherlock
Infiltrating the NSA
to use Cherise cameo beads,
which he stole from the crime scene
earlier so they can hack the NSA's systems
and Riri Williams laptop
and get all the information
that they had on name or city tell.
How can the MCU version of Atlantis
basically
and so they can wipe
Riri Williams laptop and prevent
anyone from stealing her designs
and tech from it, hoping that the NSA will
then give the laptop back to the CIA
because it was worthless
wherever Ross could go
and get back for them properly
because he currently worked for the CIA,
at least until the end of the movie
when Val had him arrested.
One of the
the big surprises, the movie too,
is that within the CIA, they also reveal
that Val had been his ex-wife.
But the idea is
that since the events
of Falcon and Winter Soldier,
she become much more powerful
within the CIA, within the government,
just in general.
We'll get to that in a second,
because that's part of like a bigger play.
Like she was always part of the film
they wrote in.
There wasn't like some cameo
they added at the last minute.
It's meant to set up a bunch of stuff
that's happening
throughout the rest of Marvel Phase five.
It'll also tie in a little bit
with what's happening
during the Secret Invasion
series in the Evil Scrolls.
The reason the NSA had Riri Williams
laptop was because of their fight
in Escape.
Earlier in the movie,
the authorities had raided her workshop
and just taken everything into custody.
At this point, she had already been taken
by a tumor named Frida to Taloqan
to meet with Namor and he was able
Everett Ross was able to join her kimono
beads from the crime scene, even though
Val revealed that she knew the whole time.
It was just kind of tailing him
to find out more information.
The beads.
I had the boat
before you ever even got there.
Every conversation
you've had makes you rest in peace.
But it's good.
Well, for us,
because at the point that Shuri is taken,
the Wakandans didn't have any information
on talking her name or they didn't
really know anything about them.
There were some loose legends
and some rumors, but that was about it.
Even though the word Wakandans
are meant to be very advanced.
So they were just trying to get
as much information on them before
they sent Nakia on the rescue mission.
They said the whole Everett
Ross scene here is meant to be an homage
to Martin Freeman and Benedict Cumberbatch
Sherlock characters.
If you didn't watch that series, I did
videos for all the episodes years ago.
It was great.
You can still find those videos
by just typing in Emergency.
Awesome Sherlock in the search bar.
Before he became Marvel's Doctor
Strange, Benedict Cumberbatch
was mostly known as Sherlock.
That was the thing
that really blew him up in pop culture.
Same thing with Martin Freeman.
He played a version of Watson, on that,
bit of trouble to at that, Of course.
Yes. Enough for a lifetime. Far too much.
I want to see some more.
Oh, God, yes.
The thing is, they've never actually
had a scene together.
Like Doctor Strange has never had a reason
to have a scene with Everett Ross.
So, like,
they never had a reunion in the MCU yet.
Not really expecting that soon.
Like Avengers five or Avengers
six Secret wars don't really expect
too much Everett Ross
going on in those in the scene.
While he's trying to infiltrate the NSA,
he's pretending to be a character
called Clive Reston,
like sort a fake name he's using,
but that's an actual Marvel character
inside the comics.
That's the foreign agent that he knocked
out at the beginning of the clip.
Like he knocked out the Clive Reston
character and stuck him in his trunk.
He was originally written to be James
Bond's son within the Marvel Universe,
but because of licensing issues,
when he was introduced, like many,
many years ago, they couldn't
use the James Bond name outright.
But that's why in this scene, he's
using his British accent,
pretending to be a foreign agent
from the UK because in the MCU,
like in the real context, Everett Ross
is supposed to be from the United States,
even though Martin Freeman in real
life is British.
Also, when he talks to the other female
NSA agent about trying to capture
spymaster in Harmon Taylor.
Those are two different
old school Iron Man characters
from the sixties and seventies.
They're relatively minor characters.
The reason they blurred the laptop out
is because of a weird licensing issue,
if you can believe it.
I know it makes it seem like
there's some cool secret behind
Riri Williams Ironheart laptop here.
It does have some Iron Man inspired
designs on it, but they didn't budget
because it was hiding some huge Iron
Man secret that spoils
the plot of the Ironheart series,
which is happening later this year.
They actually blurred it because it's got
stickers and designs, logos from other
brands and music artists that Disney
and Marvel didn't have the rights to.
And when they do stuff like that,
they put popular logos of other companies
or brands that they don't have the rights
to in their movies and shows.
They either have to pay the other brands
to use it, or more likely
they just go through a bunch of paperwork
in trouble with the legal departments
of both companies.
It's a huge nightmare,
so it's a big hassle
and you don't really earn extra money
because of it or anything like that.
And because they deleted this
and it wasn't in the actual movie,
they didn't need to go through
all the legwork
of getting all that paperwork done.
But because they wanted to release
the footage is a deleted scene.
Their only two options are to do
the mountain of paperwork after the fact,
or they just blur this in the scene,
which is a vastly quicker, cheaper,
easier option.
You probably seen that
in other TV shows and movies
where like someone will do an interview
but they'll blur the t shirt out.
It's because of the logo.
It's all because of a licensing,
a rights issue.
When he figures out the toilet pipes above
the room are an option, he flushes.
Cherise Camejo B's down,
so they're close enough to the area
for the Wakandans to get the data
they need from them in a race.
The rest of the data on Riri
Williams laptop.
So the NSA and the CIA can't steal it.
Presumably after this they just had
somebody pretend to be a janitor
and go in and fix the pipes
and steal the beads back that way.
But the whole idea is
they wanted to render the laptop inert
so the NSA couldn't
steal anything from it.
And they would give it back to the CIA
because it was worthless
wherever Ros could steal it back
because he worked for the CIA.
For a point like the end of the movie,
the next place Everett Ross will appear
is during the Secret Invasion episodes,
which was supposed to release around
April or May.
They haven't given
an exact release date yet,
but there will be a little bit of overlap,
probably with The Mandalorian season
three episodes, or it'll start like right
after The Mandalorian is done.
I think the Marvel and Star Wars
people decided to stagger their series
a little bit more so they didn't
cannibalize each other's audiences
like they did last year A little bit.
If you don't remember, last year there was
actually an issue where a couple of Big
Star Wars series premiered on the exact
same day as Big Marvel series.
Surprise, surprise.
Disney figured out
there are seven days in a week
and they didn't
have to put everything on the exact
same day.
They'll probably continue doing that
where they just
stagger series a little bit
so they don't overlap quite as much.
But at the end of the movie,
AQ used her new Midnight Angels armor,
which she'll continue to use in future
series like this in a coyly Disney
Plus series that they're developing for
her character to help Everett Ross escape.
So he's a fugitive now
going forward into Marvel Phase five,
but he'll be helping
Nick Fury and Taylor's
solve the plot
behind the evil faction of Skrulls
trying to take over the world
by replacing the government leaders.
They're not doing an exact copy
of Secret Invasion from the comics.
Like, you're not going to see versions
of every single Avengers character
who are secretly skrulls.
But like Rhodey,
seems like he plays a relatively big role.
You see him in a couple of really
big scenes, so there will be some big
crossover characters
as part of this big Skrull plot.
And because it's the first big Marvel
Phase five series, they're using it
to set up this long
running, Dark Reign inspired plot,
which is kind of the way
things flowed in the comics,
like it went from Secret Invasion
to Dark Reign in.
The comics were basically Val
and Thunderbolt.
Ross in the MCU will use that
political paranoia, the infiltration
aspect of it, to turn the United States
probably other countries too.
It is something more akin to police
states cracking down hard
core like we need to be careful
or else the skrulls will come get us in.
Out of that,
they'll have a very dark reign
inspired vibe during Marvel Phase five,
which will culminate by Captain America
for a New World Order in the Thunderbolts
movie
where Thunderbolt Ross
is supposed to become
the next President of the United States
and the Red Hulk in right now,
Val is already the director of the CIA.
So it's like like riding
that wave of popularity
they get from getting rid of the scrolls
by taking credit for it
and use that power
to do all kinds of crazy stuff.
I've already done a couple of videos
about the Thunderbolts movie, too,
because Val is supposed to be
continuing the Weapons
Plus program with Thunderbolt Ross's help,
they recast Harrison Ford as Thunderbolt
Ross.
He's played presidents before,
so it's not a big stretch for him.
And he'll use the weapons
plus program to create the century.
Who did come from the weapons
Plus program in the comics?
It's kind of an offshoot, but
it was the same basic principle interest
the thunderbolts with cleaning up her mess
when the sentry starts
to go crazy because of the way
he got his powers, he developed the void.
Personality in the void
starts to take over.
He starts hearing quote
unquote, voices in his head.
So be like having homelander
running rampant.
But have you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references
in this deleted scene
that I didn't talk about in the video?
Just write them below in the comments
in because Amy and the WASP
Quantumania is coming out really soon.
My review should post in the next couple
of weeks as soon as they let us do that,
everyone click here for my new video
on the DC trailer that they dropped for
the new Superman movie, the new Batman
movie, like all the new rebooted DC movies
and click here for my brand new Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania
Trailer video in Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.